you were like the original hippie to me
you know what i mean the first one hey i
was never a hippie i was a beatnik yeah
you think so yeah i saw you as a hippie
and now hip comes from the jazz phrase
doesn't it hipster
down the line yeah but hippie you know
what phrases are like when they're tied
to events uh after a while they get a
little bit i always figured you had like
the best life man am i the hippie okay
i'll be hippie yeah you're a hypocrite
there's no way you're changing it really
no you can't get out of it no it's stuck
it's there i am
okay i'm a hippie and your your life has
been very full as a matter of fact we
were just talking about your your two
kids i know and you have do you have a
second hand or something five kids we
have five one marriage five kids i have
two american kids which are very visible
they
brought up in hollywood i didn't bring
them up ionian right you never were
married to their mother no it was a
rebound relationship between two periods
in my life when i met my teen muse who's
sitting in the other room linda i met
her in 65. but you've been married like
20 years right yeah yeah i met linda
lawrence in 65 she had this kid with
brian jones the first sensationalized
relationship did you know about that no
i don't know it was a love at first
sight yeah during 1965 i was in love
with linda all the way
and then she couldn't make another
relationship straight away so we parted
four years in the 60s a magic spell held
us apart what happened was i wrote all
my songs for her she put me on the chart
she's the teenage muse during that
period i was on the rebound all over the
place right every woman that i met i
wanted to make into linda it was
impossible of course but i had two
children over a period of four years
then linda and i met again magically
then we had three children so i got five
you call your wife your teen muse i like
yes amuse is a
painter paints a girlfriend or a wife
again and again and again a wrong writer
writes songs for one woman again and
again and again but you're really in
love and uh yes check this out
you want me to sing a bit yeah you do
you do it you'll assume a couple of uh
greatest hits and we'll talk about your
new record
[Music]
well after that great
intro by howard
thrown like a star in my vastly
i open my eyes to take a peek
to find that i was by the sea
gazing with tranquility
till then when the hurricane in my head
come singing
[Music]
had
[Music]
foreign this is the song for linda right
okay
this is the one
sunshine came softly through my
window today
[Music]
but in a while
you're gonna be mine i know it
do it in style
then you've made your mind up that
you'll go into their minds i'll tell you
right now any trick in the book now baby
yeah that i can find
any that i can find
[Music]
the studio gonna sing along i'm just mad
about saffron
saffron's mad about me
[Music]
[Music]
for
foreign
[Music]
what the hell was a hurdy gertie man
anyway we were talking about this this
morning it's a guy who used to come into
town with a very strange instrument 200
years ago he wound it up with a handle
but it wasn't an organ it had the wooden
wheel that bowed strings and he was the
herdy gertie man but did you have like a
drug reference there was that supposed
to be the hell the hurdy gurdy man in
fact is was maharishi and all teachers
that bring uh the message at the right
time for millions and he sure did then
again i'm a hurdy-goody man because i
sang songs of the mystic what i wanted
to do at 16 and a half was it's an
incredible compulsion an obsession
really to put mystic lyrics into popular
songs it wasn't
an accident that i happened i wanted to
sing these songs and i wanted to project
this this map you wrote all those songs
too right and i did and so when i wrote
the hurdy-gurdy man it was in india and
the beatles and i were out there
meditating in 68. you hung with those
guys yeah we took the guitars we didn't
only take a spiritual aspiration with us
we didn't forget the guitars so we wrote
an enormous amount of songs there in 68
and they came back and did the white
album and i came back and wrote herdy
goody man